Vall this is the general form of a
circle X minus H the quantity squared
plus y minus K the quantity squared
equals the radius squared H and K are
the center ok that's the center point of
the circle R is the radius so let's look
at an example so you have X minus 2
squared plus y plus 4 squared equals 16
so where's the center for this circle
it's at positive 2 negative 4
ok so let's just write that down to
negative 4 and what's the radius it's
the square root of 16 because this is
the radius squared so we want to take
the square root so the radius is just
going to be 4 going back to the center
for a moment notice that it's the
opposite sign so minus 2 it's actually
positive 2 positive 4 it's actually
negative 4 because if we look at the
form of our ok equation of a circle it's
X minus H see X minus H is actually just
2 y plus 4 is really like Y minus and
negative 4 so Y minus K is negative 4 ok
so if you wanted to graph this locate
your center point 2 negative 4 okay
right there
the radius is forced you're gonna go up
4 you're gonna go down 4 right 4 okay
and the left 4 from the center and those
are some easy points to identify and you
can draw your circle like that so this
is an example of a circle let me show
you another example a little bit
slightly different variety say for
example you had this one x squared plus
y -3 squared equals 1 okay in this one
what's the center of the circle it's 0
positive 3
with a radius of one so we've got zero
three radius equals one and again if we
want to graph it zero on the X 3 on the
Y a radius of one so we're going to go
up 1 down 1 right 1 and left 1 and
there's the graph of our circle so this
has been an overview of how to work with
the equation of a circle review it if
you need to and I'll see you in the next
video